hey guys how's it going gifts is here
today in my kitchen mad about cake first
introduce yourself tell us about your
channel and then I want to tell you guys
a story of why he's here right now
my name is Josh John Russell and I have
a show called man about cake where each
week we tackle trends in the cake world
it's a lot of fun and she called and I
came
well you guys so you basically we
stalked him online and you guys tweeted
him two times and told him to come and
make a cake with me and now here we are
exactly between it works today we're
making something really exciting we were
discussing what we should make it
clearly you guys already know that I'm a
huge Nintendo fan but there's a new game
coming out for the Nintendo switch
splatoon - my plates will dip I am NOT a
gamer at all I ordered one of these and
in about two months I'm gonna have like
a beard and long hair and be like we
were still playing it because I get
addicted to video games if you guys
haven't seen his channel he actually
makes really incredible things
[Music]
I'm so embarrassed no one like it's what
AM it might smell like I mean good you
made good stuff I liked your PEC
medications awesome Thanks
so what do you think are gonna be the
challenges with making this today
I think the carving part and the fact
that this bridge is very small sorry and
I got a little over ambitious with our
template it's large it's gonna barely
fit it's gonna fit
okay we can move some things around okay
like the wine okay let's get started
what should we do first we gonna make
better cream okay it's doing how do we
do that I'm gonna show you so we're
gonna take I know you like store-bought
icing that's there's nothing wrong with
that at all it's delicious but I like to
take it and make it a little bit like
more my house so we're gonna like take
it up a notch by adding things to it and
it will feel they could tell me I just
don't make helped me because I don't
know how and I'm like let's get the
mixer no I don't think it'll working
water I don't think it will we need like
either spinny paddle it can I help you
God
do you know what you have yes I'll see
you later Justine it's so amazing this
is like a limited and we made like a few
of these they made 500 which I thought
they made a thousand but 500 is not very
many they probably still have it I don't
think they said really nice Coco Wow
this stuff is made in Italy so it's so
fancy well I get it out it can't be here
I don't deserve it you do deserve it so
we're gonna use so this is really nice
Coco yeah so you don't use this to bake
but you use it for finishing soccer do
we have everything that we need actually
let's do one more spatula we're just
gonna put it all in here so could be
this is great so thanks for coming to
hang out thanks for having me is
exciting so so far originally it found
you because I wanted to try to do
content and I didn't know how that's how
you found my video yeah oh that's cool
and then it looked difficult I was like
I'm done
he just need to go to my house and I'll
show you it's easier than doing
buttercream I just like can I just stand
back maybe don't call yourself I need
your hands oh no it's why I love nuts
all right we're not gonna measure kind
of like put some in here and see what
happens
perfect is that you like that already
that measuring life we didn't it kidding
we should put more in we gotta put
butter in its room flutter because this
has non butter in it it's like some sort
of other fat like Coach your mouth a
little bit so when you add butter it
cuts the sweetness and it feels real and
it actually smooths out so much better
but you have to leave the butter out for
a few hours to get soft
oh you can't boil it over my favorite
important I have watched your videos
[Music]
this is a lot faster or you could push
it down I thought about it if you lift
it up a little bit it gets the stuff
let's go ahead add the vanilla what and
then you can taste it as vanilla and
yeah it's Madagascar bourbon vanilla
bean paste they smell it yeah let's see
it has a little flecks in it or don't
let me just shake it a little bit let's
dance in that his he all the little bits
yes then it looks like you actually used
well vanilla super-pan yeah oh you know
a vanilla pod you have to like cut and
like scrape all the seeds out I don't
know okay and then we'll do a little
sake and that seems weird but salts for
pastry is just like salt for savory it
brings out the flavors and well pastry
stuff is what are you ready yes I'm
ready you taste this isn't that so much
better that's so nice love it well now
we're gonna cook own it's gonna be even
better
here's the problem making you never
taste anything that I make I'm sorry
here guys two cones but that's measuring
yeah but I'm just like INX so you get to
keep the rest of this do you know what I
call up tablespoons what
Tibbals I call teaspoon
a kiss how many Tibbles is that a lot of
there Wow well this mixer so awesome let
me see
definitely more isn't that so good the
best compete around your life this is
really good I thought my trash tapes of
good this is delicious
so did you go to school I did I went to
culinary school
Wow so I'm not really for making cakes I
went for pastry but like when I was
younger going into like a bakery and
seeing like the little star tips skivvy
do cakes and like them to do that one
day that's amazing where my parents
thought it was crazy and then all of a
sudden chefs became cool there's YouTube
YouTube is exactly I'm just gonna make
sure it's so good it's so good it's
really good tastes like homemade
buttercream I wouldn't know that's true
I mean I probably had it well you got
they call in my show and will make real
buttercream
you guys should tell us what we should
make on my show yes leave a comment
below and let us what we should make
okay so now we just magically cleaned up
no no how do you do so now we're gonna
carve the cakes okay so what I did was I
made a template so I blew up a switch so
then you laminate it that way you have
to make it again it is get dirty this is
a lot of prep usually I just like figure
out what I'm gonna do today before yeah
a little bit work we prep a lot on that
mush
here's the deal with the sculpting it
has to be cold this is pretty cool yeah
yeah it's pretty cool oh I don't use a
lot of store-bought cake so look at you
so official always making your cakes and
stuff so if your template get rid of
this stuff it should fit almost exactly
you try to keep your knife as straight
as possible and we're gonna carve out
should I get a bigger yeah well get it
maybe get a serrated knife you can use
mine till I have little upstairs that's
why I keep is written I kept standards
something's happening up there so I
don't know if like this one would work
got this is this is my first machete her
excited how do you have that I have to
know why you have this this is my bowie
knife operated that for the Game of
Thrones cake oh I'm so sorry
I think you should do it because it's
funny any any knife will work but when I
said serrated that's I didn't mean
oh so aggressively serrated like maybe a
steak knife would have done but I keep
this by my bed let's see if it works
just keep it as straight up as possible
[Music]
that's good and it's all straight and
stuff boom
yeah that was awesome we should taste
the cake it's good right that's nice
that's a nice taste not bad at all
before you well don't use that don't use
that nine where was this little mine see
so you just carve like make sure it's
getting rounded let's see okay maybe use
those a little night for that
so yeah just cut it in half so we can
fill up a buttercream this cake is
fragile okay here you go uninitiated oh
right there
okay just right here put it put it on
this okay okay that's great there you go
Oh Frank like maybe look at that perfect
like our batter you escaped I didn't mix
it that well there so why do that that's
okay no one will see it inside so the
goal is once we get it because before we
do the funding we have to make sure they
keep his really cold so that's why I'm
worried about their fitting in the
fridge
I see we could put in the freezer I only
have a cooler I don't like a walk-in or
anything that's what I want James
walking that's where you can put the
bodies oh ok so first there's not
there's knives in the bedroom right sure
if you're the female Dexter what's
happening it's something clear and
butter great is that not good no it's
just you'll have more butter cream hmm
no just don't let it break get your
hands way out of it I'm all the way in
it in it looks pretty even you're not
not don't take off too much just like a
little bit okay is this this I'm doing
it yeah you're doing it I'm gonna trim
this a little bit yeah
even this should I trim that right here
too yeah it used to be a little flatter
I just totally took over your cake I'm
sorry
totally vice but look here - maybe a
little bit this I'm still doing it
control free it's okay should I start
icing as well or should I like dig a
little mmm let me look at that side yeah
you're good I think you guys do you hate
Hey
just put that it's supposed to go in the
cake down
[Music]
that's your shelf down there and then
we'll be right back now what do we do
we're gonna do another coat and put it
back in the fridge
okay so now we're gonna die fondants
yeah presently oh what's that I don't
want to mess this up because we're news
colors that this is a matte silicone
you're gonna love this thing yeah so
like if you ever want to like temper
chocolate on it you can do all kinds of
stuff and nothing sticks to it do what
temperatures do a video on tempering
chocolate okay so I'm doing the joy
Khan's in splatoon game which there's a
neon green and neon pink and they're
beautiful and I'm doing the joy Khan's
for my own show
okay so yeah with this this is a really
good fun it's called red shawl okay so
text a little piece first so you don't
commit to the whole thing and then what
if it comes out the wrong color I have
more it does okay just in case I need to
look at me do you have the colors that
you can you have to match that right do
I try just a little this yeah maybe oh
my goodness I'm making a mess
so do I stop doing this now how did I
get pink in mine it's happening so guy
that's here so doing it this is so
sticky and then you're just gonna knead
it until there's no streaks
we're gonna go with that that's pretty
good you have so fax I don't know
keep doing this a lot Oh No here you so
let me actually told you this you have
to hold it sorry you have to kind of
fold it in I didn't want your whole
tutorial because I got scary see isn't
my job fun this is great I'm sweating so
just like put them apart so they don't
get okay they're not making out of there
no touch
and then we put it to the side while we
wait there's more
we're gonna cover the whole thing in
black and then we'll put these two sides
on I get it in the screen with buttons
so I said before it wherever your yes
whenever you're doing black by black
block you can't really use it right out
of the bucket you have to knead it first
so that's what I'm doing just get a soft
I'm still doing this that's that okay
yes here I've got it as wide as that
probably needed to be so now I'm gonna
go the ball you just wanna make sure
it's gonna fit over this okay
oh I knew some corn stalks here let me
see if I can shape it up I keep taking
over your project and I'm sorry
so fine with that very very sorry cuz
you got a longer this I love baking okay
a great job that looks amazing
pick it up oh I probably shouldn't have
this just not designed like this I'm
gonna plop it on pick it up
yeah go quick oh gosh okay what do I do
now I do not what do I do
Oh God okay slide roll go okay arms are
gone Devon so now you just rub it and
make sure it's sticking to the
buttercream isn't that fun that you're
doing so well
I'm just wanna make sure it tucks really
well nothing okay up in there
these are really awesome you can keep
one of you want what they're like a
little exact oh I love not I'm gonna
trim inside here
get all the excess off
what did you do imagine that's what
we're covering it's okay okay it's okay
great hmm so we've got we've done so
many things today I'm so lately
overwhelmed so many things and we got
more to go oh my goodness so now we got
to make our side okay let's the color in
it so we're just gonna roll out a small
piece of each and then we'll glue it
into our cake
[Music]
that good that's perfect okay I get it
as straight as you possibly can oh
you're doing good there that looks
straight yeah well so then the sides you
want to keep this straight - what's this
this is called confectioners glaze it
makes things really shiny you want to
smell it
yes oh I had a flashback to childhood do
you remember they were those things that
you like that you blow bubbles
that's exactly what it smells like yes I
know you're talking about it's like a
goop that you put my gosh all that stuff
I don't know yeah just go in the same
direction this is completely edible
right it is it's just beetles great what
made out of beetles like cockroaches and
[Applause]
you ready for the head you have a sword
I think you're fine
yeah I hate bugs I'm still trying to get
over the fact that I'm brushing beetles
on a cake do you make flour out of
crickets it's really high protein weight
really yeah I mean I might've eaten I
don't even know you wouldn't know
because it doesn't taste like crickets
it tastes like whatever you like the
brownie that you're eating oh my gosh no
okay now we're gonna make our buttons
and stuff because show you my surprise
yes you're gonna die the screen oh yeah
we don't have anything on the screen
would be very difficult to paint it
would be so I printed it and it looks
okay
isn't that so cool that's like the Start
menu that's the screen this is so I
could eat that know it yeah oh it's my
selfish
I'm not House mad about cake so there's
this place in orange like I didn't go
off it's like hey can you put the sugar
sheet through the printer please you go
like a specialty cake store Kinkos for K
yeah well that's what they do Kinkos for
K so it's called cakewalk ending and
cake supplies Wow I just did I just
emailed in the end she pretty - right
now fun time
[Music]
like what also don't have some white
boys are you doing okay ready to stick
yeah we'll have to flip the stuff on the
back this is all I'm getting you okay
that's all you get
[Music]
yes that looks so good it looks awesome
can you believe it
cor I mean you believe it but can they
believe it this is so exciting we should
like clean up about it
[Music]
our cakes are officially done here they
aren't you did so good thank you so much
for coming over here making a switch
game yeah we'll have to get more this
was fun when you get your switch you're
gonna have to let me know I will we are
gonna be playing it splatoon - so here
we should we try it
yeah let's taste it okay kind of tried
this paper that's a lot of frosting
I mean it's taste fine like it's not
something I'd be like wow I want to eat
this whole sheet hmm oh it's actually
pretty good right oh my good coke oh
yeah I mean even this basic cake be you
bought from wherever is greater the
grocery store aisle of the grocery store
naked cake it's a thing that's a lot
more knife okay well you can't chase it
awesome thank you so much we're coming
here and hanging out it's healthy is fun
of course make sure you guys go check
out his channel I'll put a link in the
description where you can check out all
things man about cake I love it it's so
good thank you it's cool well thank you
guys so much you'll see later bye
[Music]